JUST IN THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS
TO VISIT THE CRISIS THERE LET’S
BRING IN STEVE MILLER FORMER
WHITE HOUSE SENIOR ADVISER TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
GOOD MORNING, STEVEN, THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY.
>> GOOD MORNING.
WILL: IN THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS
WE HAVE NOTICED THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEGUN TO
DESCRIBE WHAT IS HAPPENING AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER AS A NORMAL
SEASONAL SURGE, NOTHING GREATLY
OUTPACING WHAT HAPPENED UNDER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THAT
DEFIES THE ACCOUNT AND NUMBERS
WE HAVE SEEN.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO.
THIS VERY STUPID IN POLITICS TO
SAY SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
DISPROVEN WITH DATA THAT’S GOING
TO BE RELEASED IN A MATTER OF
DAYS.
SO, AT THE END OF THE MONTH,
THEY ARE GOING TO RELEASE THE
MONTHLY BORDER STATISTICS AND
WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO SEE IS THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS APPREHENDED SINCE THE
DATA HAS BEEN KEPT.
JUST TO PUT THIS IN PERSPECTIVE,
DURING THE UNACCOMPANIED MINOR
SURGE THAT WE ALL REMEMBER VERY
WELL IN 2014, RIGHT, THAT WAS
THE FIRST YEAR THAT PEOPLE
REALLY CAME IN LARGE NUMBERS AS
UNACCOMPANIED, UNDER THE AGE OF
18 ILLEGALLY ACROSS OUR BORDERS.
FOR THE WHOLE YEAR, THE TOTAL
WAS 68,000, JUST SHY OF 70,000
OR ABOUT 190 PEOPLE A DAY.
RATE NOW THEY ARE APPREHENDING
IN THIS AGE DEMOGRAPHIC BETWEEN
6 AND 800 PEOPLE A DAY MORE THAN
FOUR TIMES WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
THAT TERRIBLE CRISIS THAT WE
REMEMBER IN 2014.
THERE IS NO PRECEDENT, NOT JUST
IN OUR COUNTRY, I WOULD ARGUE
THERE IS NO PRECEDENT IN WORLD
HISTORY FOR A RESETTLEMENT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE ILLEGALLY ENTERING
A COUNTRY ON THE SCALE.
AND WHO IS GOING TO PAY FOR IT
ALL?
WHO IS GOING TO PROVIDE THE
HEALTHCARE?
EDUCATION?
WHO IS GOING TO PROVIDE THE
HOUSING?
THE ANSWER IS HARDWORKING U.S.
TAXPAYERS WHO HAVE JUST BEEN
THROUGH A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
PETE: STEVEN, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD SAY WELL,
THIS IS IN THE NAME OF
HUMANITARIAN.
THIS IS IN THE NAME OF A
DIFFERENT APPROACH THAN THAT
HARSH APPROACH OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEIR CLAIMS
THAT HEY THIS IS OKAY.
EVEN THOUGH IT’S UNPRECEDENTED,
MAYBE THEY DON’T ADMIT THAT,
BECAUSE WE ARE BEING HUMANE.
>> YEAH.
SO LET’S TAKE THE EXAMPLE THAT
WAS BROUGHT UP AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT JOE BIDEN DID ON
THURSDAY.
SO, A REPORTER FOR ANOTHER NEWS
OUTLET ASKED JOE BIDEN ABOUT A
STORY.
THE STORY WAS THAT AN
UNACCOMPANIED MINOR, 9 YEARS OLD
CAME HERE.
THE PARENTS WERE BACK IN THEIR
HOME COUNTRY.
UNDER BIDEN ADMINISTRATION’S
THAT CHILD SEPARATION IS BEING
PERPETUATED.
THEY WILL BE RESETTLED IN THE
UNITED STATES, THEY WILL BE KEPT
AWAY FROM THEIR PARENTS, THEY
WILL STAY HERE INDEFINITELY.
THEY MAY GO YEARS, EVEN LONGER
WITHOUT EVER SEEING THEIR
PARENTS AGAIN.
THAT’S JOE BIDEN’S POLICY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION POLICY
WAS TO CONTACT THE HOME COUNTRY,
CONTACT SOCIAL SERVICES, CONTACT
OUR EMBASSY AND CONSULATE AND
ARRANGE FOR A REUNIFICATION FOR
THE HOME COUNTRY AND TO WORK
WITH THAT GOVERNMENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT FAMILY WAS SAFE.
THAT’S THE DIFFERENCE.
JOE BIDEN IS SPLITTING UP
FAMILIES ALL OVER THE WORLD FOR
YEARS AT A TIME TO BRING THEM
HERE TO AMERICA AT TAXPAYER
EXPENSE.
DONALD TRUMP WAS HUMANELY
REUNITING PEOPLE AT HOME.
AND THE TERMINATION OF THAT
POLICY, THE DECISION TO KEEP ALL
ILLEGAL ALIENS UNDER 17 HERE IN
AMERICA INDEFINITELY IS
TRIGGERING A TITLED SURGE THAT
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN BEFORE,
AGAIN, AS LONG AS CAT THAT HAS
BEEN KEPT.
JEDEDIAH: STEVEN, I WANT TO ASK
YOU, WE HAVE TWO PROBLEMS HERE
WHICH IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
CONTINUING TO COUPLE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE ALREADY HERE.
SO EVEN IF PRESIDENT BIDEN WERE
TO COME OUT AT THIS POINT AND
SAY STOP COMING OR YOU WILL BE
SENT BACK, THE QUESTION IS ONE,
DO THOSE PEOPLE BELIEVE HIM
BECAUSE ALL THE PEOPLE THAT JUST
CAME ARE LIKELY GOING TO BE ABLE
TO STAY, I WOULD ASSUME.
AND, SECONDLY, IS THAT ENOUGH
AND DOES THAT ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM WE HAVE NOW WHICH IS
OVERCROWDING OF FACILITIES?
WHAT HAPPENS TO ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE NOW?
WHAT DO WE DO?
>> RIGHT, SO, COUPLE THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, JOE BIDEN HAS THE
AUTHORITY RIGHT NOW UNDER WHAT
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD IS CALLED
TITLED 42, CDC PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITY THAT DUMP PUT INTO
PLACE.
YOU COULD TAKE ALL OF THE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS THAT ARE IN
FACILITIES TODAY AND BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF LINING UP CHARTER
FLIGHTS AND SENDING THEM BACK TO
THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
ONCE YOU DO THAT, THE
OVERCROWDING WILL DISAPPEAR
WITHIN DAYS AND THEY WILL STOP
COMING AND THE PROBLEM WILL BE
SOLVED.
IT IS A VOLUNTARY CHOICE OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
SECONDLY, TO YOUR POINT, THE
RHETORIC IS MEANINGLESS WHEN IT
IS CONTRADICTED BY REALITY.
AND SO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
GETTING IN, NOT JUST MINORS, BUT
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
ADULTS TRAVELING WITH CHILDREN
AS WELL ARE BEING RELEASED.
WHETHER THEY GET IN, THEY GO ON
TO SOCIAL MEDIA, THEY REPORT HOW
THEY GOT IN, WHERE THEY GOT IN,
WHERE THEY ARE NOW, AND THAT
INFORMATION TRAVELS BACK TO
WHERE THEY COME FROM.
SO, UNLESS YOU CHANGE THE
REALITY THEN THIS MASS ILLEGAL
RESETTLEMENT IS GOING TO
CONTINUE NOT ONLY AT ITS CURRENT
UNPRECEDENTED PACE BUT TO REACH
EVEN GREATER HIGHS HIGH THAN WE